a lot of big announcements coming out of
Fordham flat rock today so I don't know
exactly where server let's start with
that one point six billion dollars you
won't be investing in a new plant in
Mexico simply put would you have made
this same decision regardless of what
the president-elect had said are you
doing this because you don't need those
cars to be made there or because of the
president-elect well David we would we
would make the same decision and the
main reason for canceling the plant is
our our next-generation focus was going
to be built in that plant and what we've
seen is a market decline in demand of
small for small vehicles here in North
America so we don't need that capacity
and we're going to take the focus that
was supposed to produce there and
produce it in an existing facility that
we have in Mexico so you would have made
the same decision regardless of what the
new administration was saying about this
plant because they'd been fairly
critical but you did as I understand
talk with the president-elect and the
vice president like today tell us about
that conversation why did you give him a
call well first off we wanted to to let
them know the announcements that we were
making this morning and they were very
pleased that we were making the
announcement of investing seven hundred
million dollars in our plant in Flat
Rock Michigan to build a a to high-tech
an autonomous vehicle and a fully
electric SUV and they were also very
pleased that we're going to be adding
700 jobs over the next couple of years
which builds on the 28 thousand jobs
that we've created in the last five
years so they were pleased with our part
to contributing to economic development
here in the US but as you say it was a
Ford decision it was not something that
the president-elect can really go out
and say he did this for America well it
was it was much best for our business
but as you can imagine David we look at
all factors as we make these kind of
decisions and clearly we see a more
positive US manufacturing business
environment under president elect Trump
we see the pro-growth policies that he's
outlining and the tax and regulatory
reforms so this is a vote of confidence
that that he can deliver on those things
when part of the vote accomplice is a
seven hundred million dollars that
you're investing in Flat Rock seven
hundred new jobs in Michigan there
if you look at the overall Ford level of
employment will it go up by 700 yes
overall we'll be adding these 700 jobs
which again adds to the 28,000 that
we've created over the last five years
and David as you know even today we are
the largest employer of hourly
automotive workers in the United States
and we're the largest producer of
vehicles here in the United States and
we're one of the top exporter's and
we're very proud of that a mark when you
talk about exports and imports we're all
reminded day of the tweet that came out
of the president-elect having to do with
another car company starts with aji ends
with an M right that had to do with the
board or tax adjustment if the country
went forward it would require
congressional action with a border tax
adjustment what would that do to Ford
business across the Mexican border well
we'd have to look at it in total and
obviously the the Congress that's about
to take office is going to be debating
that so we'll stay very close to that
understand what it means for our
business but to put it into perspective
David eighty percent of our sales here
in the United States comes from vehicles
that are produced here in the US less
than fifteen percent of our sales comes
from imports from from Mexico and we're
one of the top exporters so it's not
just looking at you know will there be
for example you know some kind of taxa
border adjustment tax on imports but we
also have to look at exports and that's
what we'll look at as we look at the
impact on our business well and to get
ahead of ourselves a little bit here
have you run the numbers because as you
say you're a major exporter not just an
importer and as I understand the
proposal for a border adjustment tax you
get a credit as you export it just as
you got a tax coming in net net would
Ford be better off well we're running
we're running the numbers right now and
as I mentioned we are one of the top
exporters but we're going through those
numbers right now to understand what it
may mean for our business okay one of
the things that you have done by this
move and talking with the
president-elect is to establish a
relationship with his income
administration you've given them a gift
in some sense you did it because it was
right for your shareholders a gift
nonetheless what would you like to get
back
and did you talk with the president like
to add things like fuel economy things
like currency manipulation things like
tax reform what do you need it forward
back well we inform the president-elect
and the Vice president-elect this
morning so you know as we look at the
business going forward our priorities
what we'd like to see is very clearly a
level playing field for trade in opening
markets we would love to see tax reform
also at the same time regulatory
certainty and regulations that are
aligned with market realities those are
the type of things that we would like to
see going forward and finally mark as I
say there's a lot in this announcement
and I think everyone will be focused on
Mexico and the conversation with the
president like there's also a lot in
here but electrification of vehicles and
what Ford sees is a future for v's tell
us about that part of the announcement
well this is a massive announcement for
us because we're investing 4.5 billion
dollars in electrified vehicles and
we're going to be bringing out 13
electrified vehicles over the next five
years we've talked about seven of them
today including an f150 hybrid a mustang
hybrid a transit plug-in hybrid as well
as a few others and what we're really
doing as a company is we're taking the
products our most popular products and
what people love about them and making
them even better because with our trucks
you'll get more capability with our
performance vehicles you'll you will be
able to get more performance from our
sports cars and of course Mervan you'll
get more productivity so it's a really
big announcement and commitment on our
part and to lead in electrification here
in the US and globally and leading it
strikes me really finely mark is
terribly important because you don't
want to be caught behind as customers
start to think about car companies and
who is big and electrical vehicles can
you be in a leadership position
absolutely you know we are the number
one seller plug-in hybrids here in the
United States today and the number to
seller overall for electrified vehicles
so we want to build on that you can see
that through our announcements today and
keep in mind we only talked about seven
of the 13 electrified vehicles that are
coming so there's more to come